a new study out this morning shows many
midsize SUV struggle to light up the
roads at night the Insurance Institute
for Highway Safety looked at headlights
on 37 different models only to received
good reviews 11 models received poor
grades Kris Van Cleave is in Washington
with the disturbing test results Kris
good morning good morning the federal
standards for headlights are set in the
lab not on the roads and this testing is
showing that many just don't perform all
that well this Dodge Journey was one
that rated poor and the concern with the
poor rated headlights is they may not
light up an obstacle down the road in
time for you to avoid it look closely
can you spot the person crossing the
road they're virtually undetectable in
these headlights on the Kia Sorento
which ranked among the worst of those
tested by the Insurance Institute for
Highway Safety matthew braun below is a
senior research engineer when i say the
kia sorento 35 miles an hour's is really
about the fastest you should be driving
with your low beams on headlights on the
volvo xc60 scored the highest compared
to the Sorento you can clearly see a
person 100 feet away and even make out
deer 200 feet down the road properly
position the Volvo's headlights also
won't blind oncoming drivers if you are
involved in a crash at night with better
headlights you might have avoided that
collision the trek is ready you can
begin your run IIHS began testing
headlights last year and whether on
sedans small SUVs pickups for now
midsize SUVs they've largely
underperformed in this round researchers
evaluated 37 SUVs with 79 possible
headlight combinations when fitted with
their best performing headlight systems
11 models rated poor the lowest score
possible only two got top marks the
Volvo xc60 and the Hyundai Santa Fe
equipped with highly specialized
optional curve adapted headlights if you
are in the market for a new car and
safety is your top concern take a look
at the IHS safety standards when it
comes to headlight performance but also
rollover and cry
affection airbags the IIHS test is not
mandatory and all the vehicles evaluated
meet or exceed federal standards car
makers are beginning to make changes to
headlight design the Institute says
because of this testing we reached out
to all the companies that received a
poor rating most told us they are
evaluating these test results that
includes Kia who points out the Sorento
was given a Top Safety Pick rating by
IIHS Cale all right thank you Chris